[Music]
several years ago we found ourselves uh
christian and i did in a star-studded
group i think is fair to say very fair
to say yeah in
uh we were in vegas in this group one of
the stars in the star-studded group was
cameron diaz name drop well yeah but i
have to for the i understand the story
so so
uh christian and i were kind of in her
wake right we were walking through a
casino crowded casino packed she was in
very high heels she's already extremely
tall yeah obviously beautiful yeah and
cameron diaz so there are three things
already right like she's beautiful
tall
very famous yeah she was like a famous
gazelle who was like striding through
and she walks with real purpose you know
she's athletic she's like and confident
so she walked walking with purpose we
were like you know those little dogs
that are walking with bigger dogs and
they have to like take as many like
twice as many steps so insulting to
little dogs
to compare ourselves yes never in my
life have i felt less seen than i did
that day yeah i could have been naked
and screaming obscenities
and no one would have looked at me
i just got a visual
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short we're
your homunculus homunculus hosts justin
long and my brother christian life could
be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
fellow homunculus uh i love that lie how
much you lie would be or
homunculi
plural oh you know my latin teaches any
latin shorties out there latin scholars
i had a really funny latin teacher named
uh mr ondeck he was very sweet very kind
but um
i don't remember
learning too much i just remember doing
bits in the class not necessarily his
fault not at all not in fact i think
predominantly my fault um just wasn't as
the fact that i can't remember that i
think would make him very unhappy i love
that word homunculus because it reminds
me of that scene wallace
hopefully future guest in manhattan
where um diane keane keeps referring to
her ex-boyfriend and she's like oh you
know he was such a great lover he was
this dynamic like animalistic lover and
then uh
woody allen meets him in a bookstore and
it's ball shawn and he goes
you know i'm stunned you know you talk
about your ex you love her and this
little homunculus walks out
that's so good but that's how i felt in
cameron diaz's wake yeah diaz's
uh d is
completely unseen oh yeah in a good way
because oh it's great because uh
who wants to be seen yeah in vegas and
you got to really witness the whole
thing and and be in it being like in
vegas like that already is a bit like
being on like a people safari you know
it's like um and so being in cameron
diaz's wake
being like her caboose it was like being
in a protected safari jeep you know so
nothing's going to get to you nothing's
going to see you like they're not
there's not going to be any like oh [ __ ]
you're the guy in dodgeball you know
drunk yeah gambler's true uh so we got
to really experience the the the sites
it was fascinating yeah it really was
and she seemed like she had i've i've
witnessed this on other occasions with
people similar like
impressive kind of famous tall people
like that i i noticed that they have
like um blind blinders on i mean i
imagine it's how presidents feel yeah
they can't look around they're just so
used to everybody looking at them i
noticed that about asa gonzalez we were
walking to new york the other day and i
even said to her i was like i started
noticing all the people again i'm
invisible when i'm walking with her uh
and i just noticed people looking at her
because she's just
you know she's somebody you want to look
at and and um and i said to her do you
notice like what do you notice that like
somebody specifically and she was no not
at all so it sounds like and she said it
was a bit like having blinders on that's
how cameron was walking that day um so
why are we talking about cameron diaz
and vegas and vegas yeah those two
things well i'll tell you i'll answer my
own question your own rhetorical
question yeah yeah
uh our guest today played cameron's best
friend in a movie called what happens in
vegas so it's a very it's a very
appropriate story that's a great start
even if you didn't like the story it's
very appropriate it's also how you know
correct me if i'm wrong it's also how
you know our guest today it is our guest
being lake bell
lake uh yeah somebody i met through that
group that star studied group i don't
know if she was in that she wasn't no
but then we subsequently went up
subsequently went on a um a vacation
with
her and cameron and my friend togo and
scott it was really fun privileged life
i know i know been lucky anyway um
lake is uh very funny very smart i mean
you're about to hear it uh but she's
done a lot of things since then this was
about 10 years ago she's since become a
very accomplished director she directed
and wrote uh critical darling
called in a world you normally don't use
that term but it very much applies yeah
i think it was like the toast of
sundance it was one of those movies that
was darling it was very much a darling
yeah and in fact i think she may refer
to it as such oh really yeah so if you
haven't seen that she's also in she was
recently in a show with dax shepard
bless this mess it was called but i
would say her uh the crown jewel of her
career has been in a world if you
haven't seen it it's very funny highly
recommend really good movie great movie
and uh certainly for christian and i
grew up in
a household where one of the parents was
a voice over actress and that's what the
movie's about it's all about um it's
weird to refer to our household in fact
and say one of the parents i don't know
why i did that so formally one of our
parents excuse me
i thought i thought i'd mitigate that
formality with a burp um
yeah our mother good use of the word
mitigate thanks i've never heard
mitigate and burp in the same sentence
yeah it's like a class suit thing and
wow in reference to a very really it's
just nicely done thank you you're
getting better at this oh thanks you're
picking your teeth hey
why i want to paint the picture for the
audience okay because i'm getting better
at it uh okay well
you know her you're gonna meet her if
you don't know her and um you'll
probably be so much charmed by her i
would guess uh yeah so get ready to
potentially be charmed by the very
charming very smart and funny talented
lake belle
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello
[Music]
i don't know if a small human
[Music]
that's nude
uh may enter this
yeah
i shouldn't have said might i should
have just said please count on
okay oh
well now i'm going to be disappointed if
it doesn't happen i know this is where
you're going to live and you're going to
live with that anxiety through this yeah
wait how old how old are they like
um five and three
you know it's big [ __ ] over here and i
mean that literally because
my kids uh my three-year-old just
learned how to crap in a potty and boy
not to brag listen i'm bragging big time
outwardly bragging because that means
that we don't have
any more diapers in our house and like
when you have kids it's like a really
[ __ ] big deal and i bet
and what it means in my family because
it's different with everyone what it
means in my family is that now we're
allowed to get a second dog
so that was that was yeah that was the
deal
so now you get a pitbull
you have room for more [ __ ] in your yep
only
and me too we both were like listen yeah
only one person at a time
cannot know where to [ __ ]
right one living thing yeah
uh wait what that's really funny i uh my
brother has been
i shouldn't say this we can cut it out
because he's very sensitive about me
talking about his kids on the show but
he um
my my nephew had been they've been doing
the training okay
and uh
the potty training and it was very funny
for an outsider to come and like observe
it i'm sure it's not funny when you're
like in the midst of it and when you're
i mean i mean like farting and pooping
is funny i mean
even when you're entrenched in it it's
like
it continues to be amusing in some
capacity i mean you're always looking
for something to laugh at so you know
did the kids have like i'm sure you have
a yard which is another nice thing about
la versus new york now during the
pandemic you know yeah that but i think
what i like seeing the nuggets are like
okay so
i live in a you know
a very diverse like a neighborhood where
there's just like all kinds of languages
and you know which i do like again i'm
from you know living in brooklyn like i
really enjoy that
and um
and you really see whole families
because of the quarantine you see whole
families going for a walk like i brush
my teeth i look out the window and i see
like the grandmother the mother the
daughter and the daughters
you know children like all taking walks
all the time you know it's so like
old school you know i know
i've been noticing that i'm in
connecticut uh not far from where i grew
up
it's nice yeah but you know it's like
bucolic suburbie but um
i i've noticed far more than than i ever
have even as a kid even before the town
really
grew because it's a commuter town and
um it's grown a lot since i was a little
kid can you say where you're you are
right now in fairfield well in a little
town called southport next to fairfield
do you know what fairfield well no i
went to boarding school
in uh simsbury connecticut
do you know do you know westminster
westminster my dad went to joke but i
went to westminster um yeah right next
to miss porter's right because so do you
have heard of that cause all girls
school i figure you would yes yes yes
your dad went to choke my dad went to
why did you go to jail no no i have a
friend no i just
for some reason i thought cho was a
in all
girls no no no no but it would make
sense because he he likes the ladies so
it would all add up either way really
yeah yeah
wait wait is he remarried now
yeah he's he's been yeah he's had two
marriages and you know that's fine
um well you you yeah huh no i'm just
saying like but yeah chill's been around
for a long time
and um
westminster why didn't you go to cho
then i i don't think i got into cho i
think westminster the main thing was
westminster has a huge
big badass
big kid um summer stock theater there
and i remember touring
schools and my brother went to boarding
school at 11 so i just always knew that
like as a kid you'd go to great school
you know it's weird yeah wow indian
mountain also in your hood um oh wow but
anyways so then yeah i saw that theater
and it was theater
that what i wanted to do i was like are
you
i'm like 14. am i gonna get to can i go
in that theater you know and yeah yeah
that's right so did you stay there like
over the summer did you actually do
summer stuff
i did i ended up doing summer stock
there it was my first professional job
as an actor um
was
this i graduated from westminster at 18
and i
auditioned for their summer stock
company while i was on campus and i
i played a french maid and a farce
in uh like moliere it was just like a it
was called move over mrs markham and it
was like i was like
you know and like
the whole thing you know but yeah
yeah it was great it was so fun yeah
that's how you got your is that how you
got in the union
no no i i don't even know i mean i don't
think like summer stock was like off the
grid i don't think well
i can't remember i don't think that's
how i got in the union i had to be like
tap heart lead for
some [ __ ] later on yeah i remember that
yeah i'm right so did i what was your
first job uh it was
it was it was a summer well it was a
summer theater
um it was at new york station film it
was um i think it was a reading
and
i yeah it was for the for at for uh
equity actors equity that was my first
thing and then williamstown and
yeah oh god i i've been having such
because i've been cleaning i've been i
just moved into this house not too long
ago and so i've been moving
stuff from my old childhood home where i
just kept all those
relics of you know when you first start
doing movies and stuff
you keep everything i kept like call
sheets of every day
you know i was like
yeah yeah and so
i still can't even though now it's like
ah call [ __ ]
some of the luster is worn off a little
bit but i still can't bring myself to
throw them out no i know i always like
keep one call sheet from each
show you know or each movie or something
you know what i mean this but obviously
the ones that i
write and directed i i always the the
the start sheet the start call sheet
the final day
yeah or do you mister
because in a world that was such a great
dream it was your directorial debut
right it was my first feature i had i
did a short film before that but yeah
but and it and it it got such a claim
and it's such a successful
feature especially for your first it's
crazy no yes
nuts crazy
yeah it made like my second feature
really hard i was like oh [ __ ] you know
i mean like um there is that
sense of like i i knew i was gonna make
movies for the rest of my life and make
content and direct and you know i knew
from the second of being on
the set of my short film i was like this
is
okay so this is yeah this is like this
is where i'm gonna be so
now knowing that
you know it's like okay you gotta be
ready for the journey of having ups and
downs and yeah i always knew going into
it that
you know after especially after in a
world being so well received my short
film also worst enemy was at sundance
and and was extremely well received like
in terms of like accolades
and that's how you were able to get the
financing and get the yeah exactly
exactly it was like i wrote and directed
that short film and i took it it was at
sundancing competition and like won some
stuff and yeah that
became my sort of visual calling card
and my sort of proof of concept
um uh to
to gain financing uh for but like does
that then like spoil you in terms of the
mindset that you're going into these
next because i i christian my brother
and i just directed our first feature
and oh awesome so
yeah so but also i mean like
know how much you have to put into it
how consuming it is um
and and we are now
on the verge of sending it out and we're
kind of bracing ourselves for the
reception of it however that may
be but um
but i i'm asking i'm wondering like what
that then if god willing it's successful
like yours was and what kind of mindset
does that put you in for that for the
next one i mean oh here's what it's like
yeah i mean i think
you know um
i think you always have to
make
what feels right for you like i have
this um without the judgment and the
sort of um thinking for other people or
thinking for critics or thinking for
your audience too much you know what i
mean it's like
the best and the most sort of um
sort of compelling kind of pieces of
content and and stories and
um films that i've seen are just wholly
original and wholly confident in what
they
are set out to do so
it's like you know that kind of
you know it's i feel like even with um i
do until i don't my second feature it's
like
i sort of just knew in my gut especially
it was so interesting actually with i do
until i don't i knew in my gut that it
wouldn't be as well received and and i
yet i still forged forward as if
i you know it was
my
next you know the next sort of master
mastery yeah my next job why well sorry
like why did you think that what made
you think that it wasn't going to be
well i just there was something like in
my gut i just knew that like it felt
like a sophomore you know like that i
would
from going from in a world which was
such a darling it's so hard to think
about
you know
kind of like what i felt like there was
a lot of expectations from oh yeah from
sure
like it was like the expectations were
like too aggressive i felt well
yeah
it's like your first one it's like oh
whoa you made a movie uh let's give it
exactly a novel with an open mind yeah
yeah like
that's good you know and then yeah of
course it was like it was
people liked it and they were they were
satisfied with it and they felt
like oh and they sharpen their knives
yeah yeah now the next one better be
yeah so people are you're already going
into it from a critical standpoint it's
like you're already going into the
sophomore endeavor you know like with
with some dupes up a little bit you know
what i mean yeah yeah um yeah like can
she do it again you know what i mean and
like totally also just psychologically
people like to come after
you know it's if you're innocent and and
haven't done anything and you're not
threatening to the
filmmaking community it's like oh yeah
we'll support that and we'll we'll give
you we'll pat you on the back but
if you yeah yeah i mean you're right and
and i feel like to some extent i was
like
i was like you know what like when it
wasn't well received and i actually i
had my um my second kid right alongside
with my
second yeah he was was he well received
he was very well received but the point
is like it was the first time my second
movie i also was first time making a
full-length feature that i wrote
directed and produced and starring while
having a one-year-old like it as a
mother so it started it was like
you know i i knew that challenge was
ahead of me and i knew without like
resenting my kid i just knew that it
would be a different or neglecting your
kid yeah i mean you have to like yeah
i can't imagine so that part of it i was
like okay when when reviews were tough i
actually didn't read them because i had
just given birth to my my son
and
um i knew they weren't great and i was
like you know what i
it really helped i had trouble with my
the birth of my second son and um but
but but that's to helps put things in
perspective of like what's important
right
and then part of it it was like man i'm
in the game like oh they're gonna
[ __ ] they're gonna give me like
coming after they're coming after me i'm
like
okay like i i felt like
yeah every filmmaker is gonna
like
oh yes here we go speak of the devil
here we go who's this oh it's all fallen
apart
who's this guy oh here's a bomb oh i'm
looking at a butt i'm looking at a
three-year-old butt okay who is that
this is ozzie
hi ozzy what do you want to say
that's my friend justin
hey ozzie can you make a good fart sound
look at this face
okay great so ozzy can you tell your
joke to justin he loves jokes
why
not or dress what is a ring say what
does a rain cloud wear under her dress
clothes on her
dress
hmm what does a rain cloud wear under
her dress
i don't know oh
it's a solid uh
solid joke
my favorite was the direction that you
gave him and i was like what we need to
do is articulate a little more just to
set up the joke
and that's not true liberty is very
important in comedy i just yeah i mean
clarity you know you need to kind of
know where you can stand but he's great
that was funny ozzie's very funny
hey ozzy can you tell me another one
ozzie can you tell me another joke
say the one um
um oh you do one you're you do you just
go go off just make one up just make one
up oh we're feeling shy can't do it okay
hey ozzy i'll tell you one hey ozzy you
wanna i'll tell you one okay he's gonna
tell you a joke hold on okay
what okay
so he doesn't want to hear your joke i
do oh all right all right okay good
because i didn't have one you were just
gonna make it up i was gonna riff
yeah i riff all day long because there's
a letter like mom tell me a joke and i'm
like
what does the
was
why does the coffee cross the
road you know well that's do they ever
like crack up over i mean that's the
best it's like bye ozzy
oh he's gonna go play down there and
make some noise for us
you were right fully naked
he it's hard in quarantine to ask a
three-year-old to put clothes on because
why right you know what i'm saying right
why it's
as well as especially now that you know
that he doesn't run the risk of just
pooping wherever yeah
oh let it let yeah just let it oh look
you've got another one
there's no nova that's no no
nobody has like a loincloth on she has
uh banana pants they're under underwear
with bananas
um
you guys everybody gets it they do oh
this is the best i love this
there's scott there's my husband hey
scott
what's up scott
so he said there won't be any more
issues oh okay
oh wow oh who's that's awesome
because they're all like why are you
oh is this the one room we're not
allowed to be in so we would like to be
here
exactly it's the forbidden fruit hey you
guys
okay thanks guys bye
hi nova
i'm witnessing i just want to tell
everyone i'm witnessing some really like
adorable family stuff in the background
yeah yeah smooching and genuinely
affectionate
it was genuine they're they're it's hard
either
either that or nova is an amazing
actress she i have a feeling i think
it's so interesting like seeing your
kids and like what they
have a proclivity or interest in you
know and it's like nova is an incredible
rhymer like she can like write songs on
the spot she'll be like
you know she's just like and you're
gonna take it like she like kind of yeah
does you can't even come up with a uh
example
you know
but she's so good
where'd she get that from i wonder i
mean
she's a rap artist is what i'm trying to
say like she's so good and so quick and
sharp and
i am in awe of her and so part of me
i was like oh man maybe she's you know
she has two creative parents i mean
maybe she could be like a
you know singer or something but she
hates
she said to me i don't like
when you have a song and you want to
sing it but then you have to go on like
in front of everyone who's looking at
you
and i'm interested yes so that was the
opposite of me she said jim morrison
yeah exactly
show yourself jim um because what is
scott is a uh he's escaped he is a
tattoo artist tattoo artist a fine
artist and he's in the cannabis business
as well because he has a a company
called bibo
do you
do f with bibo
bibo therapy
it's like
that sounds very familiar yeah rose gold
beautiful
like
um
yeah edibles well there's pastels which
are little edibles and then there's like
oh
okay lake yeah i might uh i yeah we'll
talk
yeah okay um
yeah he does that and then he's also a
paramedic
jesus really he's a night school and
he's a paramedic yeah oh
was that a new development yes
yeah but he's a prep worker so it's like
he's like a full-on he's been a prepper
since og days you know what i'm saying
oh so that he must be this is like his
time to shine oh he's like yeah i know
he's like oh pandemic and like world
global shutdown he's like uh-huh
yeah that was 2004 for me yeah he's like
i have everything okay right
just have a bunker do you guys have like
a so it's a great question
um we don't have a bunker but i'm sure
but by the way we might
like he might prepper's probably if he's
a good prepper he probably wouldn't have
have you tell me yeah yeah i mean he has
night vision goggles
wow
wow
did you know that going in or or was
that something that was slowly revealed
over the course of your uh that's what i
want to say the level of prepperness has
enriched over the years
i mean you know we are a married couple
for a long time we have two kids we live
in a suburb like
i have
totally come down
uh
like this one time i came down from
you know upstairs and i was like i need
to get the case you know one of the kids
needs like
i need water you know whatever i want
hugo juice and i'm like okay so i like
went down it was completely go they
speak spanish they they dabble
and
and as i i'm trying to learn um
so then i
great uh mucho gusto um but then
i come
i come down
in complete pitch black darkness
and and there's a figure
sitting
in the in the breakfast nook and i'm
like oh my god like there's a beige like
i literally was like and then i turned
on the lights and there's scott sitting
there
with the night vision goggles
like step brothers yeah and he's like
hey and i'm like no
no
what was he doing just meditating no
he's
it was hilarious from his point of view
i nearly peed myself it was so
terrifying
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
does he do the paramedic stuff now is he
a paramedic now wow um he doesn't go on
call right now like he's not on call he
is a certified in all of the
50 states like he is a nationally
certified uh paramedic
we've had scares in the house with the
kids and stuff so i think at a certain
point his his prepperness and then yeah
you know ozzy's birth was super hairy um
yeah nicu for 11 days and then um
oh my god yeah and that's a whole
another can of worms and then um you
know uh nova has epilepsy so we just
have oh wow we have some like stuff in
the house so you know he wanted to um
not smart yeah he was just like be
prepared exactly so yeah
and oh see that's
yeah yeah that's a
totally reasonable
i mean
for anything like admirable
version of
prepperness it's preparedness it's not
like he's one of the finest
men i know i mean he's just incredible
you know he
he's just um he's one of those he's a
little he's like a little magic you know
what i mean like he's like sets and
he sends out like
intentions for things and it occurs he's
like
kind of karma police you know what i
mean like
he's good like that you're saying that
you're like wincing as you're saying it
like you don't relate to that kind of
stuff well i i you know we you admire it
i admire it and in our house i will say
we do a lot of like
we're very in the privacy of our own
home we're very sort of like juju we're
like pro juju we do a lot okay he's from
louisiana
you know
so there's a little creole there's a
little bit of like mysticism and
mystical kind of yeah
when you go back to visit this family
did they all have like uh creole accents
are they all like uh
please please stop doing that um
or whatever that accent would be
no i no i don't even know that one um
but no yeah he does not they do not have
accents they
um
you know their his family all live in
texas now basically the majority of his
family left after katrina like any
surviving people
so they're just all in houston texas so
i just have a large
um sort of in-law in-laws
contingency in
texas so i have a lot of families do
they do they come out and do your
parents come out to la to be with the
kids they used to um
yeah oh yeah i mean in texas too i i
don't i was gonna say though i will say
they don't have
like
the accents but the like cooking is on
fire you know what i'm saying it's like
a lot of barbecue a lot of just
slaws
yes there's well there's just a lot of
amazing cooking so i will say that i
always like gain a lot of weight
yeah oh i miss new orleans god i miss it
there uh and and texas um
i miss austin a lot
yeah i would i would live there i feel
like that right we could all live there
absolutely yeah
that's where is that where you know
world was it was that at south by
no it was in a world was that sundance
was that sundance okay and um um
it's so crazy i do until i don't was
supposed to be at tribeca and i was
seven months pregnant and i couldn't fly
oh yeah for a movie for what movie for i
do until i don't
um which is my second feature
yeah that you probably haven't seen
because a lot of people haven't seen it
um yeah i want to see it now uh what are
you planning on doing another one yes
i'm writing my third feature um now and
my show just got cancelled which i don't
know if you know i heard yeah i didn't
know how to approach that oh my god it's
fine we did we you're fine yeah i think
because i'm so proud of it and i did a
great job i've never been on a show more
than two years so i was like oh this
will be interesting you know like
because you signed that contract on
network television you're like oh my god
like is oh it's sad that i mean i'm
thrilled but is this like seven years
now
um right i know i know that's why i know
it's been it's always difficult for me
to
commit to it's scary right because
you're like oh this is such a wonderful
opportunity but you're like just
you know as an actor too you're like oh
am i gonna be this person for seven
years yeah you know yeah what's my l and
also i mean you know you've got two kids
now what's my life going to look like
seven years are you kidding me seven
years yeah yeah and i mean look i feel
like you know i
i created the show with liz merriweather
blessed and i
oh that's right with liz yeah and well
liz is
yeah so listed new girl for people who
don't know liz created the show new girl
and just a really funny smile and she
wrote uh like great
yeah exactly [ __ ] buddies aka
no strings attached which i was in no
strings attached which is why we know
each other and then we've been friends
ever since and then we were like oh yeah
you know we were dear friends and we
were like let's make a show together and
so we created the show we wrote the
pilot together i directed the pilot and
then i i oh [ __ ] executive produced it
together and then i started with that
and oh [ __ ] ed begley and pam oh dave
oh it's such a great cast jesus [ __ ]
but like
was it is there any part of you like a
creative part of you that is not
relieved but like it was getting more
difficult to invest in it to come up
with ideas for new episodes
here's the the truth on that is like
it i was like happy either way you know
it's like
it's a beaut the
the family we created was
unprecedented like
we did not have we've all been on tv
shows and films and it's like
sometimes the the experience has a lot
of challenges and this was not that i
always worked really hard
one of my biggest commitments to you
know working as a director or a producer
is is is is like the general
ethos and and feeling and vibe and
energy on the set and so
i in casting i made sure everyone and
and and in crewing up everyone was happy
to be there
and
and that made the experience especially
if it was going to be seven years it
made the experience so enjoyable
and so such
you know it's like you create this
beautiful ecosystem and i
for that part of it i'm so proud of what
we made and i
i can't wait for people to see it but
it's like we did 26 episodes of
something and you're like okay you know
i feel satiated i don't yeah i'm so sad
that it's done but i feel
i don't feel like
i feel like we created something
beautiful and we put it out in the world
and because i come from film it feels
very
you know it feels like i did it and now
it's done and that's okay emotionally
for me to conceptualize
yeah i guess that is something that you
cultivate more on movies movies is more
of a vagabond lifestyle and the
idea of just creating something brief at
the time period it's just all about like
how you know the time period is
different whereas if you're on a show
i've never been on a
a long-running show so i don't know
really that feeling of um
well i think at every point right like
because i've talked to my friends too
and it's like there's like an expiration
date i would say that seven years is a
little too long like yeah i feel like
four years it's like a marriage you know
it's like yeah at four years there's
like a hump you gotta get over and then
maybe five six but you can kind of get
to seven years but it gets like at that
point
totally
everyone i know who has been on
successful shows even like beloved shows
and i don't want to name any names but
like everybody i know they're they say
this a version of that thing which is
[ __ ] you know after two three years
it was i was on a show for four years
and i remember
so i shouldn't say that i i don't know
what that feels like but i had such a i
was in two out of three episodes i had a
smaller part but i i remember after like
i would say after the second season
they were really stretching sometimes
with the plots and
you know it it just
there was an environment the environment
wasn't as fun it wasn't as like what's
happening this week it was um it just
felt a little strained i guess yeah
i mean look like how to make it in
america is a show i did for two years oh
yeah perfect like i mean i would have
loved to go another year but i feel like
two three years is cool like you know
it's like that oh yeah i forget
appropriate you know
but yeah with brian greenberg and louie
what a cast yeah uh victor richard
yeah
julian farino i worked with last year
yeah julian the director um
yeah uh the best uh former guest of the
show uh like this might be a little
inside or a baseball so we can cut it
out but i'm i'm curious just because
we're chris and i are in fact we should
definitely cut it out we're going
through this thing now with the cut of
our movie which is uh
we we haven't signed our director's deal
yet um and the producer is freaking out
because he wants to include this clause
wherein uh
we once once it sells to a distributor
if it does we don't have a say over what
they do with it they can basically do
anything they want with it um have you
yeah i mean
i i it's interesting um
okay so what's the budget of your movie
it's a million it's like just just a
million it feel that's very
i mean that's normal um i had to do that
um
for
my
i think both yeah for both of them but
what ended up doing is a good faith deal
where
again it's like in your best interest to
you know
consider your filmmaker when making
broad
um
marketing and
uh
visual and
decisions for its well-being you know
it's like when you're putting out into
the world like
wouldn't you like the the input that's
what it works
exactly it seems kind of productive not
to and and originally we had there was a
year i remember the deal was like
it's you have it for a year and if it
doesn't you can take the festivals
during that time and if it doesn't sell
which makes sense then like all bets are
off and we can take it apart and rework
it that makes perfect sense because like
it probably needs reworking if it
doesn't sell anyway
um but now they're saying oh no a
festival cut and a
in a uh distribution cut a sales cut are
two different things which i've never
heard of um
it's interesting i'd have to look back
on my yeah yeah i'm curious totally
insidery and not worth putting in the
show but uh just curious what your
experience with that was because we're
really up against but sidebar like if
you want a sidebar i can ask jet because
jet will know my my producer will know
the answer that would be i would love
that yeah in fact i looked at you for
your number i i know at one point i had
you oh you're coming up you're cutting
up um i just want to make sure i have
your number afterwards uh okay great um
uh oh oh uh animated harley quinn series
yes tony hale and alan
harley quinn i play poison ivy um it's
on
dc universe and now sci-fi
um
i love
this project i am not i'm only a voice
for hire on it
um but
the sort of interpretation the the i
don't know i think the challenge and the
kind of um undertaking of you know i
love voice acting obviously i made a
whole movie about it um and yeah sure i
feel very honored to have taken on
poison ivy who's an iconic character
yeah um yeah and and with those guys
like with alan tudyk yeah i mean all
those dudes are incredible and
the
this you know it's really like about you
know this sort of girl friendship at
least between
um from my perspective i feel like this
show is so irreverent so funny and so
sharp and like
dirty and violent and like just who
plays harley quinn um kaylee cuoco
coco um oh cool yeah yeah
you know is it a friend of mine said
recently because we've been doing these
trivia nights uh with my friend dan
which has been so fun and and my brother
and i tried to put one together and it
was a disaster it was like
it was such a um
so we had so much more respect now for
what dan was doing and i said to dan
like i was apologizing he was like you
know because it took a while for it to
get started then there were all these
technical problems and he said
look after doing this thing every week
and putting the time in it is such a
relief it's kind of like when you he's
like you're going to probably feel this
after directing this movie when you now
just act in something it's going to be
like oh take your time i'm good you know
it must be such a totally relieved i
mean that's the thing is that i'm
blessed this mess i'm like ep and so i'm
constantly in prep and production and
post at all times but but it must be so
nice to just show up and show up and be
like what am i saying today you know and
then yeah yeah and then you get to
improvise with yourself alone in a you
know in your sweatpants just like in a
sound booth and like talk [ __ ] and
totally and the character you know made
you know she's super super um
ry and and sarcastic and um do you do
you do anything to your voice like this
like
[ __ ] it's like in this space you know
what i mean she's just very
um
it's so well written too my god i think
honestly like
it took me
a back like how sharp and witty it is
and it's kind of like
when you think about these like larger
than life superhero characters that are
like villains in the show it's also like
all the in-between moments that of just
like getting from a to b so you know you
have harlequin and
and poison ivy you know sort of like
taking on some hijinks and then at heist
you know and then it's like um do you
want to get indian later um yes just
text me just like text me what you want
i'm not saying i'll just tell you right
now because we're on the phone well yeah
but then i'm gonna get it wrong so if
you want
just specify exactly what you want and
then you know it's like i mean it's like
yeah and it's all animated so it's got
this incredibly like improvisational
kind of ratatating like throw away stuff
and then these like wild you know so
it's
yeah it's an amalgamation and recently
uh harley quinn this is a bit of a
spoiler but it's also like it's out
there so [ __ ] you and just go watch it
um but yeah
but um harley quinn and poison ivy have
a very tight relationship so much so
that they get romantic so oh
boy
okay so i don't think america is ready
for that i think they are i think they
need it kidding they are no they're
definitely involved okay yes yes
needed you know it's funny i'm thinking
of the original movie poison ivy and i'm
thinking of the fact that i have poison
ivy all over my arms uh because i
cleared out some bushes yeah but and now
i'm thinking we were on i'm remembering
some trips we were on together you and
me yes
oh my god i wish i could see you for
this um
we've known each other for a long time
yeah yeah i don't know why it didn't
occur to me until i mean of course i
remember well i have a terrible memory
those were fun there was
yeah and then i remember like being in
new york with you at one point and like
and you had just gotten an apartment do
you remember yes yes yes
you were yes
like that blue building right the blue
building yes okay yeah and i remember
being like the lower east side or
something you were like yeah i just got
an apartment
i was like oh [ __ ] i was like what are
the [ __ ] i just remember being like
what are the windows like in that
apartment because it was all blue like
the entire building was blue yeah drew
hated yeah he couldn't stand that uh
yeah it was it was because it was like
one would be blue and then there'd be
normal ones
there were every every third was like a
blue
uh in retrospect i i mean i have some
experiences
kind of is that
is that fair
yeah that's how it was sold to me in
fact i mean i'm like you know sex
positive so like it's fine by me
yeah
it was that's how exactly how it was
described um
in a way
oh yeah um it was the only selling
i
i it's that that to me represents now it
represents like and i'm sure to everyone
else in that neighborhood it's like
that's gentrification that is like the
worst of gentrification you know uh it
was i mean it definitely was like a big
stamp
of yeah you know a new
like like trying to be like modern and
like forward thinking i don't know but
but the point is i i was like good for
you man like i don't care like i just
well it's funny i didn't grow up with
money and so when they're like these
money makes me really uncomfortable now
so when there are these big purchases
i'll just be make these impulsive i'll
be like oh yeah that's that seems cool
and i'll just do it and then when i shop
for cereal it takes me like two hours
and i have to find deals on you know
leaks
oh interesting interesting yeah money is
weird like that yeah
yeah i get very soviet i feel like all
my soviet blood comes out i feel very
like we have to save save save um oh yes
austere yes and but i also grew up with
money so that i actually don't i'm just
being outright you know it's like yeah
it was like the 80s and like my dad was
doing well you know it's like yeah it's
just a different time but like i feel
like
because of that i'm very prudent like i
don't oh interesting yeah i don't like
extravagance i'm like
i'm like you know we don't need that you
know yeah interesting can you trace so
you can trace that back to soviet i
don't know i would joke because my
husband is
my husband really grew up like
with nothing and he yeah you know it's
like we have one egg for dinner so we're
gonna have breakfast for dinner you know
it's like his mom was so creative and
amazing and he lost his mom when he was
um uh you know a teen an early teen and
you know he's just he has a very
different upbringing and i think yeah
it's really interesting seeing his
relationship with money in mind and that
he's like
you know when i first met him he was
like he never he didn't even have a bank
account he would just like keep his
money in the freezer you know what i
mean he was like oh
you know he's just like these are the
monies i have and like frozen ass i'm
gonna yeah and it's like i wanna
you know this steak is a hundred dollars
i'm gonna buy it you know because i can
yeah you know
yeah
yeah oh i know yeah
let's
but why you know like i didn't know
interesting
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
now i'm thinking back to that time we
were hanging out are there are you still
friends with those guys with with
cameron yeah
cameron is like my sister like i love
you so much tonight
yeah you
yeah when you were with drew we we all
went on a trip together and it was very
sweet and um
so fun and it was caribbean it was
harbor island harbor island very
beautiful very
uh idyllic and
i love those girls dearly yeah it's it's
great did she give you any advice direct
directorial advice when you when you did
your movie
what who did you seek with drew or
anyone anyone you work i feel like it's
so interesting like it came from all
angles but i felt especially when you
make a short film you're like oh i think
i have
i you know i had a clear enough vision
that i was like i will i've been on the
inside and in the trenches of the
machine of filmmaking for so long at
this point right that i have been
forming and obsessing and listening and
being a respectful observer for so long
that i have an understanding of how
conceptually i want to make it now
that's true i so i for the the
um short film i allowed myself to
listen to my instincts whatever those
would be right
and then because it was like a
bite-sized thing to do and then it's
like okay i'm gonna rely i'm gonna draw
storyboards based on
just what my brain wants to see you know
and see if we can do that and then and
because that worked that game i mean you
then knew that oh my instincts are okay
yeah i should listen and then it's like
yeah and i would you know nancy myers i
worked with nancy myers um with it's
complicated and i definitely had a
heart-to-heart with her and
you know um
you know i ended up becoming friends um
with catherine hardwick and i would talk
to her about directing
um it was just like trying to kind of i
mean um richard kelly was somebody that
i um oh right
leaning on you know i just would like
talk to people that i knew who had done
it right and sometimes very very famous
and then sometimes you know
just all levels and um yeah
did dax did you ever commiserate with
dax about directing or did did he ever
direct any of those episodes he didn't
in the end um oh weird but lennon parham
um i asked lennon to to direct and then
she ended up being one of our favorite
directors so
um great yeah uh dax you know ducks and
i have definitely like shared
our war stories about directing
um and he's become a really dear friend
of mine so i don't know i love him yeah
yeah i didn't know that you were so
well-versed you knew so much about i
kind of did i kind of now that i think
about it do you remember you
yeah you were into cars i remember you
and togo went on a date yes and can't
and remember cameron is super into cars
dude so we have that in common and that
was like a big bond between us yeah is
that we both have right he was a secret
motorhead love you know
yeah dax must have loved that you guys
must have bonded over there yeah and
it's interesting like he we were both uh
parents at um
at the same preschool so we had like
this uh
he would pull up and you know i'd pull
up in like a 1988 land cruiser and then
he'd pull up and like a big fat chevy
truck and he'd be like you know with
like cool rims and you know both be like
hey what's up you know it's like yeah so
uh you know and he would be like i just
want to say i you know i have this truck
because i you know because he i think i
initially didn't know i was into cars
but
had more of a guilty he knew i was an
actor but we he had a guilty look on his
face as if to say like i know she's
eating a lot of uh gas and i know we're
at a hipster
yeah hippie actress mother that this is
because i i tow um trailers for xyz and
i was like no no no like i i hear you
um you're a bad person for the
environment but also
um but i respect i grew up you know
like in the pits of a racetrack my whole
life so i that's right your dad loved
cars right my dad um
and he
uh he owned race car tracks my whole
life and was an amateur racer in the
svra which is like sports vintage racing
and oh wow also like cool old sports
cars yes but they're you know it's like
they have their own classes so you know
it's it's all european road course stuff
so it's not like you know
ovals which are cool it's just that's
not the world that i grew up in um
um it's all
like virginia international raceway was
my dad's track and then new jersey
motorsports yeah
oh my god um like i'm sorry okay i know
i keep apologizing and then droning on
so this is the lightning round fighting
fast yeah okay uh
some of these might be obnoxiously not
lightning-ish uh what is your most
commonly used emoji oh
um
your go-to punctuate a thought i mean
you know god damn um it's a fair
question i would say there's gonna be a
long lightning round sorry sorry um i
would say the prayer prayers uh prayer
yeah
yeah i do pro prayer hands off i do
prayer hands accompanied by the kind of
like
you can't see my face so i don't know
how to describe this but uh sort of
smiling looking down a little bit a
little submissive i mean it's like
prayer hands or sparkles like i like
sparkles a lot um and the hearts the
juju but the problem is my kid like
overtakes my my phone a lot and then in
the area you know where you have like
the most recent
it's like she goes through and then she
presses a bunch of [ __ ] and then it's
like you're mostly literally
yeah yeah
all of a sudden your most recent is like
the most esoteric
weird
um emojis that you're like i can't use
any of this [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's like a witch and broccoli and a
dragon and like yeah you know like like
a pig's butt bangladeshi flags yeah
yeah uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
volleyball
oh oh you played in high school yeah
westminster yeah i love it
yeah i can see that you probably have a
really yeah
well you have you have a um what are
they called a wingspan i do have a
wingspan
yeah i was like
yeah
that's like gang well
that's not a good version what's that
tattoo i'm saying oh it's we have a lot
of transfers my husband said to ours and
we have we have uh a lot of like cool
like real tattoo looking transfers in my
house and so the kids get tattoos and i
do a tattoo too you know i don't have
actually cool i do have tattoos and
we're but i you know this is not but
that's not this cobra on my arm is not a
real one
listen when you're quarantined you're
workshopping it yeah you're quarantined
with like one of the world's greatest
tattoo artists it's hard not to get
tattoos
i bet i bet that's funny that's a funny
idea quarantine tattoos i bet a lot of
people are going to be like oh well this
was
i wasn't really committed to this but it
was the quarantine and
yeah
i i do so your kids have like really
fancy looking temporary tattoos yeah
everyone's like wow that's really
aggressive that you tattooed your
children but it's borderline abusive
yeah it looked they looked so impressive
not that we go to the park or anything
so nobody really sees them but if we go
to the sad parking lot to do our scooter
time
they are tatted up pretty hardcore
it's funny uh if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life
what what would it be you're stoned um
you wanna
you go to
um probably pickles
oh yeah yeah
do you have a brand it would just be
like it would be like you know delicate
like new york deli
half cemeteries like the real deal
uh i'm committed to clawson's um oh no
no no no i have no i have to do original
i mean i like clawson's but like i need
like oh gee like a deli stuff yeah okay
for real
um if you what's your favorite movie i
don't feel like i really dissed you on
the closets i didn't mean to be so mean
i i just no i love pickles it's the
soviet in me again coming out with all
the fermented sugar
get out of here with yourself so
um uh no you know it's funny like i've
been i got instagram for this uh podcast
and occasionally i'll i've been i've
been like pimping myself out for these
companies that it will send me free
stuff awesome is one of your team no
they should be
if they're listening but no but this
comes from me if clawson's listening
right now you need to make half towers
okay
oh i'm telling you nobody makes half
hours and it's very hard to do but you
need to do it i do love half sours yeah
it's just what it's just less brining
time it's less writing time but it's
hard because you have to preserve it
right you're like they're sitting in the
brine yeah but you have to think of a
way to do it they can do it i know they
can do it
that's true okay that's a good point
this company grillo's in fact reached
out and was like we want to send you
some i don't know if you know grillos i
think they're a boston area
pickle they're they're great great but i
think they probably do do the half brine
i'll check in with them okay um
well favorite movie do you have a
favorite movie or like a comfort movie
in corners i mean my my favorite movie
is king of comedy um
oh yeah um
i'm trying to think uh my comfort
quarantine movie would be moonstruck
oh huh never seen it
god
yeah oh
lake has contorted her face
you need to do yourself a favor and
watch men start okay okay done will do
nova has something to say yes oh hi nova
yeah tell me what's going on oh wait hey
mish would you turn on the video
so what's the proposal what happened so
what's the deal there's a proposal here
hold on what so you're saying you could
get a marble if what until you can get a
marble by cleaning up my whole room like
the whole room one more yes absolutely
that's a good deal that's a solid deal
wait speaking of having a different
relationship with money you guys
obviously have money but what that's
that that's very impressive to me that's
the marble that just happened well
listen it's impressive to you and to in
this moment
but there has been
stiff negotiations throughout the day
so all right well
then you're an impressive negotiator
she's better than me by far she was like
you have to get 20 marbles to get the
the thing that you set your mind on you
get like a marble ticket and you like
yeah and you put it up there and you see
it you visualize it but you got to get
20 marbles
and so marbles is a currency that you
then use to trade in for like
one toy yeah you work towards a thing or
usually yeah before quarantine there was
like you know it meant like a day at the
beach or like going to the the roller
rink or you know what i mean
cool yeah and then it's a great idea
it's so fun but now it's like toys now
they get obsessed with it it's like i
gotta i gotta re-tool a little bit but
anyway
the point is they
yeah so marbles anyway she's gotta get
20 but she said to me she was like i got
16 marbles mom
and i was like
okay
she was like that's how many marbles you
need for the toy and i was like
are you trying to like
do the jedi minds
because like you're saying it very
strongly and she was like yeah 16
marbles is what we always get
and i was like these are not the droids
you're looking for is that what you're
trying to do yeah like and i was like
i've seen star wars kids
go ahead yeah
16 marbles is all you need i know uh
that's really funny
where where
where would you live uh if you could
live outside of l.a where else would you
want to live i would live um in italy i
would live in like uh
it's very probably like a
you know i'd have like land in the
countryside of southern italy
okay um yeah if you could have dinner
with three people dead or alive whom
you've never met who would you pick uh
barack obama michelle obama
um
and uh
they're one of their kids
yeah i'm like that's hard with three
because now i'm like i just want to have
you feel like the outfit yeah yeah i
feel like they have two kids so i
wouldn't want to yeah
um yeah then who do you pick it's like
sophie's choice
i think
here's what i would do i'd invite my
husband to go have
dinner with the obamas and then it would
be like a double date with the obamas
and that was
oh my god forget it yeah then you
wouldn't feel the social pressure of you
know if you had included sigmund freud
or somebody like of having to be so
impressed no like the obamas are cool as
[ __ ] like i just want to ha i just would
love to have like a casual dinner you
know just like me like
just maybe we'd love that too michelle
and i would
we'd love it um totally uh
if you uh who's your favorite muppet do
you have a favorite muppet um
i i don't have a favorite muppet but i'm
not that doesn't mean i don't like the
muppets they just don't have a favorite
that's okay yeah yeah uh if you could
have one superpower what would it be
i mean to fly i mean the flying would be
great you know what i'm saying it would
just be a real
game-changer
oh god uh the possibilities um if you
could be reincarnated as a non-human
animal what would you pick what what
animals do you gravitate towards oh um
you know
it's such a great question um
i'd i'd probably be um
a like a pit bull
but like one of the pickles that has
like the silly smiles and like
wags not the singer yeah not the not the
singer but you know like the kind of
pimples that like when they're so happy
their butt kind of like tosses to one
side so i'd like wiggle my ass and i'd
like smile a lot and like what are those
moments that make you wiggle like that
what is the last you know when you you
know go out to you know when you say hey
you want to go for a walk and i'd be
like oh
you know like that's me
i don't know what to do with that
i like that i like that yeah yeah
yeah that looks like it's fun to be that
animal that elated yeah that exuberant
about something yeah
okay
um you mentioned the juju that you guys
are into can you
is there a quick way to describe what
your spiritual
ethos is
um yeah i mean you know it's really
interesting we talk about death a lot in
my home only because you know my
my
husband has yeah has dealt with it quite
a lot like he's lost siblings you know
it's like he's really lost
people and yeah and his mom and i i
think
um
you know
kids are sort of i mean my daughter is
really interested in that conversation
um and so we often talk about
um you start in the stars right you're
just a you're just a concept you know
you're just the seed of something and
then they and then the star kind of like
because you know the building of human
is almost like an electrical charge it's
a series of electrical charge that sort
of like electricity
you know
is in the mother's belly and then it
creates a baby and then you know when
the baby comes out and then you live and
you die and then you return back to the
earth and go to the stars but but what
if nova is like how do you describe that
to know i've always wondered that how do
you a kid who is interested in death
like i was i remember being a kid and
being fascinated by it and troubled by
it when nova says well what it what is
that what is death like what happens
where does he's very clear okay she's
like you go back to the store
like she's also like she's like mom are
you she's like you're gonna die one day
and i'm gonna die and we're all gonna
die but then we go back to the stars
and it's okay if your mom dies because
you have pictures of her and you'll
she'll always be with you like she's
like very clear wow
well that's very evolved yeah she's very
like wise
i'm jealous yeah i know all right i'm
like just stick with that because that
is a nice way to yeah
don't change that mindset uh
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny
what obviously unfunny i don't want to
be called unfunny
oh yeah
i'm like
yeah everybody i mean nobody it's
subjective of course there's people who
are like she looks like a horse you know
it's like i know like that's fine well
guess what dax yeah you can imagine with
dax how dax answered that
um
he said
he said he said both
no he said oh without question i'd
rather be called uh uh un unfunny
he'd rather be called unfunny
than unattractive yeah oh come on now
yeah
i think he was being i think he was
being provocative
i don't think so i think he's being
really honest i think he's really
i mean he does yeah look i'm with you by
the way
i i feel like
being attractive is like fleeting you
know
it's not i agree i think i actually
appreciate there's so many people who
either find you super attractive or
like they think you're uh you know
someone's butt you know what i mean it's
like it does you're preaching to the
choir
yeah but unfunny i'm like i really want
to bring i i feel like you can do that's
a currency you can do for the rest of
your life
oh just two minutes sorry nova okay
congratulations sorry nova
congratulations okay good job seriously
thank you really awesome
in like banana ruse running in through
the background okay almost done which
golden girl do you most identify with
dorothy blanche rose or
sophia [ __ ] ask me another one because i
feel like i they're not sharp enough in
my head
yeah yeah uh dogs or cats which do you
prefer
yeah i mean i love i genuinely love all
animals like i want to talk to every
[ __ ] animal all the time i've been
bitten so many times but
like i just go up um but i really oh
you've been bitten on the oh try
attempting since i was a kid yeah i just
like yeah don't learn my lesson but good
well here's the question like what would
you have if you didn't have a dog what
type of animal would you keep as a pet
um
well we don't have kids
so we have not a bunch but we have
a leopard gecko
two spiders called golden orb weavers
um no
kidding those things are i know
they're beautiful we have we have
actually three we have one that lives in
the garden in a corner that we feed
and let her get bigger um because they
do eventually have to they get too big
um
and then they're massive yeah you have
to get so you catch like insects and
toss them in the
web
well we have a fly farm my prepper
husband has a fly farm to build flies
for
the golden orb weavers and they are
spiders if you don't know listeners they
they're
um spiders that are that get quite large
and then they make these beautiful
golden webs golden orb weavers yeah they
leave golden webs and so how cool yeah
so we the kids love them their name ita
and leela
where'd that come from
she's great at naming and then our
lizard is called happiness
well what is also a great name where did
the name nova come from nova was like uh
scott pulled that out of his
brains um it was just like
she was almost she was gonna be named
opal and we were like her name's opal
and then um we were in croatia at a
wedding and i remember i was super
pregnant and he was like oh my god i got
it i just got i'm so sorry i just it's
not opal i was like what and he was like
it's nova oh my god you're right and
then it just kind of came to him and
then
um
and then yeah and then osgood was um
my mom it's an old english name and my
mom had proposed it to me for nova when
we didn't know she was a boy or a girl
and then so it came back around again i
always loved it cool oz great yeah um
ozzy uh well thanks like i know i know
you got you got it all going on there um
i got to go check it out i think
situation i got to see it yeah marble
i'm curious too now um i feel very
invested uh thank you for doing this it
was good to see you good to get to catch
up good to catch up and um stay safe
stay healthy youtube and uh you too and
what is it don't lose your mind what is
next
yeah yeah literally
uh what is next where can people now i
don't know
i mean
the harley quinn
yeah so basically bless this mess the if
you're like oh my god i kind of want to
see that it's on
hulu you can just watch it it's really
delight dax and i
you know kechner and lennon shenanigans
pam [ __ ] career ed begley
super nice bite-sized stuff for for the
quarantine and then there's if you want
to be a little more [ __ ] in the head
then you've got harley quinn to access
on dc universe and that is
naughty and hilarious and super random
and like is in a world uh people haven't
seen it is that on a platform now that
people can see in a world is on itunes
you know it's like on itunes okay i
think it is
you have to fact check this but i think
it's on like yeah i want to say like hbo
max or something like it's like
somewhere because someone just started
they started like reaching out to me on
twitter and stuff but it's somewhere
else but it's so good i encourage people
to see it it's so it's such a i love
that movie and uh
yeah it's and listen justin i do until i
don't go check it out it's about
i will love and relationships and um
it's very highly cool very kind spirited
okay
i love all that stuff
and i like your work i like you as a
director and an actor so okay good i'm
in um and yeah so i'm gonna go ahead and
develop a bunch of shows for 20th and
i'm currently and i'm a lot of secret
things that will be coming out soon and
you know announcements soon and then i'm
i'm writing like a feature
best of luck i i can't wait to see it
and i and now i have one to see uh and
oh and medical police on netflix medical
police yes that's starring um rob hughes
and so weird and funny it's great it's
funny and it's all of my buddies from
children's hospital days and we all love
insurance and you know
yeah
cordray
and david wayne um
yes that's really fun quarantine yes
food yeah
yes um oh thanks pal it's good to see
you guys good to see you too sorry to
take up so much but i'm gonna go check
this out with the check it out hannah
pants over here all right okay all right
tell scott thank you love you too good
to see you
wow
it's hard for me to say that title
without saying it like that i know in a
world in a world you don't hear that
that the guy who does that in a world in
a world yeah he does all those trailers
he passed away right i don't think so i
think the original guy did oh maybe
because the guy was in it the guy he's
in
shameless right isn't he an actual
shameless he does all these howie i
don't need steve highway it's someone
else he has a smaller part okay he kind
of looks like a lion you know what i'm
talking about oh man
no no but now i really want to look at
him
i don't want to look at this lion man uh
weep little lion man
remember when we were going to interview
him when he'd be great southwest very
charming you know who else is right
charming like belle yes yes all right
don't good you're you're going to get a
read get it i'm going to go you've
always been good at that um yes lake is
very charming and
i never asked her about her name did i
no and i was mad at you oh [ __ ] i was
curious about that and she has a thing
for odd names because her kids have
that's right they were like crazy
what are they osborne osborne right nova
oh yeah osborne well
oz and no
lake i wonder where that came from yeah
bummed i didn't ask her about her name
that's all right
when the kids interrupted it was my
favorite part because it would always
redirect the conversation away from not
that it was not
interesting to hear about her career
uh but in general i find
conversations with guests more
interesting when it's about like their
kids yeah their lives
and not about their work yeah so yeah so
i liked when the kids interrupted
because it always kind of
made it more real yeah exactly unless
it's like you know if it was like
michael j fox
uh then i'd want to know i'd want that
that could be 15 hours oh i know i know
but i'm saying i would want to know
about his work i'd really be curious
about all of those and i didn't just
bring you ever read his book yes of
course he follows you on instagram i was
going to say it if you didn't no i don't
know how could you see me again i could
see you i don't know how you're like
trying to tease yourself up
i was gonna say i don't think that's why
that's not why i brought him up but
subconsciously maybe it is i wanted to
brag oh probably uh yeah i i got
way too excited i i'm a grown man and i
hope he's not listening to this because
of course my next step is to um dm him
he'd be flattered if he's listening to
this
yeah i think so i hope he's not weirded
out because
margaret your fiance
uh she wisely very wisely instructed me
to uh play it cool and not because i
wanted to dm him right away i was like
she has good cool instincts yeah she
does well well that's a rip that was
kind of a humble brag
why i don't i didn't say i have cool
well her instinct to to marry you oh i
wasn't thinking of that
but now that you mentioned it
um
she it was funny when she uh
was talking about her husband and and
you said he's a skate skater and and you
started to say
i almost he's a skateboarder but you
kind of trailed off and she was like
he's a world famous tattoo artist and
fine artist and
and i but i get why you thought he might
have but he is like he could be he does
because because cool tattoo artists and
skateboarders have similar loots they
sure do but it was funny how you didn't
commit to it yeah
he's a scary escape escapement
skater
boy not boy skater man um he was a
skater man that's it was really funny uh
and she's very like
she has a lot of cool hobbies she's into
like pitbulls and
cars
i remember her being really into cars
because our friend uh and and supporter
very good strong supporter of the show
john togo uh
went on a date with her well it's in the
episode you mentioned it in the episode
oh boy yeah they went on a date and uh i
mean it's nothing
to be ashamed of it just uh obviously
didn't work out john they're both uh in
you know fine and um but
john was very impressed by that i
remember and john was on the vacation we
went on
uh with lake and i remember them i
remember him being like oh my god dude
she's like she knows my car she's like
in the car oh yeah you can see him
like liking something like that because
at the time john's not so much like that
anymore but at the time i remember him
being really into cars remember when he
had that little mini cooper yeah and he
had it all souped up oh yeah it was like
a pop i was like why would you just get
like now he might be mad that i'm saying
this without him yeah he has changed
he's not into that [ __ ] anymore
uh i like her
her choice of pickles is her favorite
snack oh right yeah i thought you'd like
that i like how she shamed you for
saying that you love clawson because
is that like pedestrian well no i like
that she has very specified taste and
she she did shame me and then apologize
for it but i don't think it warranted an
apology why should i
because
it's uh i stand by i like lawson's a lot
but if you've had a really good
pickle right like a really no i've had
good it's like the difference between a
cheeseburger and like a cheeseburger
you'd get at like a high-end fast food
restaurant are you talking about like a
good deli in new york like like i
yeah i mean i i've had really good deli
pickles again this is so privileged but
uh yeah very lucky to have had those i i
stand by clawson's really yeah i love
them so i think they're better they have
a bite in fact i bought um from a fancy
they have a good crunch great crunch
great there's not they're not
overwhelming they're not too some of
those like i like the half sour you've
been getting into the half these are
half sours no they're just sours right
but they're not too sour they're flake
they're more flavorful to me but not too
flavorful than the half sour have you
know what has really good
pickles
that that only like
one percent of people listening will i
think i know everything i say uh yeah
yeah you don't both have to like the
pickles there's two letters uh agrillo's
is the house hours i forget the name of
the guerrillas and bob's are both very
good half sours at stu leonards if you
if anyone lives there's a few branches
but if uh if you live near in the
norwalk area and you know about stu
leonard you would know about stu
leonard's yeah try the pickles i want
you know be cool to do like a pickle uh
show a podcast a pickle podcast or a
pickle test a pic
or a pickle documentary or something
where you go around i used to want to do
this with um
dumplings i wanted to go i wanted to
find the best
dumpling in the country soup dumplings
uh in in the wild the world would be fun
but like do you fun to do pickles so fun
i know go around the world look at like
sampling all the dumplings i'm sure
they're in taiwan james and i had an
idea once to go around trying to find um
make a documentary about finding the
best bidders you know bidders that you
put in oh yeah like manhattan yeah
that's such a change thing to go looking
for but it'd be funny like two bitter
guys going around the best bitters
that's funny that's funny that's kind of
a great title um
bitters bitters bitters perfect yeah but
spelled like bitter guys yeah yeah
that's funny
oh that's a good idea i know if you do a
whole
i don't know if bitter i'm more of a
short doctor i'm probably wrong but i
have my instinct is that bitters don't
vary all that much in the way that
pickles do you know who's really maybe
they do maybe they do you know who would
know is john hodgman i feel like he
knows how to make a good manhattan i'm
sure rachel maddow's really into that
it's very name dropping and you know
who's really into it is stephen colbert
when you do the stephen colbert show he
brag a lot of privileged liberals you
just rattled off there
yeah pr pro primrose
yeah you he gives you a little uh i
don't know if it's anymore i haven't
done a show in a while but he gives you
like a little uh kit oh i remember that
yeah there's like a little manhattan
manhattan okay yeah there's old
fashioned old-fashioned yeah that's what
it is see i don't know about that [ __ ]
rye
bitters
in fact i brought the what there's no
one's well no one's gonna care but i
unless stephen colbert is this thing
well i'm excited because now that the
seasons have changed i transition from
martini to manhattan when it gets called
uh manhattan's more of a fall vibe for
me it is fall winter ah i didn't know
that and and uh i just stick with my
light source spring summers but like
that's just year-round
no i have the occasional winter martini
don't get me wrong but in manhattan in
the fall when the crisp cold weather ah
hard to beat that wow i want to get into
i shouldn't get into that i sound like
such a douche yeah you do i sort of i
name it this is a douchey i also love
her choice of favorite movie king of
comedy what a great what a great
favorite
you still haven't seen joker right no
did we talk about the similarities on
with did i talk no but oh my god you got
to see it because it's so it's like
there ca there couldn't be a joker movie
i'm not saying he didn't rip him off
it's like you know you
he's in very heavily influenced by that
movie really uh todd phillips yeah oh
there's i love that movie it's so good
it's king of comedy king of me yeah me
too
that's brilliant yeah and she also loves
moonstruck which is that's one of the
movies
so great he's so good and never pumpkin
there's so many rupert popping
characters now because of your eyes just
passed yeah i know i know that's a hard
one rupert rupert popkin rupert pumpkin
because uh for those of you who don't
that's just condescending maybe but uh
that's the title character robert de
niro's character in king of comedy
directed by mark scorsese yeah score
says it's about a guy who just is
desperate to be a famous comedian and
he's very he's tumor-less almost he's
it's so brilliant but there's so many
i'm often reminded of that character uh
because there's so many platforms now on
which to be funny or attempt to be funny
that's true that uh i'm thinking of
something
in particular who thinks that they're
funny and um
you know and they really swing for the
fences they really go for it
uh but they're not and it's a really
fascinating study this movie is a
fascinating study of a person like that
it sure is um also she
loves moonstruck and that's one of the
movies along with pretty woman that i've
never seen that i always get in trouble
for not having seen me too moonstruck
yeah
trouble for not having moonstruck i've
seen parts of it really so um i should
see it i should see that and pretty
woman and stop saying and bragging about
how i haven't seen them i know but you
know what's weird i just i know i have
movies like that too and there i even
have them i like physically
oh i own them and i
i don't know what it is at night i just
it feels like an effort to
god what a douchey episode um i think
it's a good episode no no it is i'm
saying i think i'm particular
i think we're both particularly douchey
yeah but i think it's been fun yeah it
has been
it's fun to be a douche i think i really
like how she
normalizes death for her kids and oh
yeah how it's like her five-year-old i
think she's five uh she just knows that
when she dies she just returns to the
stars and that everyone dies
and i
i got really jealous of that
five-year-old girl and i wish that
me too i wish that i had that experience
i know
me too i was watching instead of the
crippling fear that i carry with me it's
a constant
about a void about a nothingness i know
you know i just read a really
interesting article about uh ghosts and
the phenomena and how freud was the one
that really made the idea of spirits and
the continuation the hereafter um
hereafter
he made it uh
taboo isn't really the right word but he
made it um an unhealthy thing like he
with freud when he was writing about
grief he felt like you had to let go he
felt like you had to um bury uh memories
of people and
he wrote a paper about it that was like
the um
like the ultimate guide to to
bereavement and
this was an interesting it was it was in
a publication called walrus
dot ca have you ever heard of that uh
walrus no and it was a it was really
interesting about how we should if
anything uh we should lean into the idea
that there may be
because so many people have experienced
things like that and they talk about i
guess mark twain was really into the
idea of it uh and and had experiences
like that very bright people and um
have gone on to write about harry
beecher stowe uh in uncle tom's cabin
there's a there's a featured character
because i think she lost a child and so
she was
felt like she had seen the child it was
really interesting it made me rethink
the whole idea of uh ghosts and stuff
and i was thinking about our movie which
i think now we mention every
i think
every episode
um interesting yeah well more on that
another time yeah sorry maybe not very
funny uh let's read a letter definitely
not very funny okay let's read a letter
this is from
emily silver
subject apparently we have the same
mother
oh god i hope i hope that's not real and
then it says in uh there's directions on
how to read it it says
read with dry humor hint of sarcasm and
maybe a bit tipsy east coast accent if
you're going for it huh that's the first
time what's an east coast accent
it depends on where we're right now yeah
i don't know
i don't know what i don't know what am i
not tipsy you're drinking a seltzer
water yeah shout out waterloo i guess
you could be a bit rye
that's what i hint of sarcasm all right
i'll try that all right i gotta i gotta
act a little bit tipsy and sort of like
maybe from boston no so i'm finally
getting to binge listen to your podcast
podcast so i'm finally getting to binge
listen to your podcast it's my favorite
right now and it's my favorite right now
yes that too sorry cassie
you won me over from armchair expert
david tennant and even the new smartless
one
do you know that one smartlist smartest
that's the one with uh jason bateman and
will arnett
hear that
yeah sean hayes yeah i pretty much can't
relate to literally any of your life or
that of your guests huh but i love
learning pointless things about
celebrities so whatever
god toilets that's entertainment
however
thank you
um well that i don't even have to inject
any sarcasm into that uh maybe she was
being sarcastic
maybe i hope however i figured i can't
wait for this however
however i figured with the way you
justin tries to relate to every guest
you have you have on who you're obsessed
with you might enjoy
the moment i realized were siblings
because your mother is also my mother
whoa
it was during the lena dunham episode
and is concerning tattoos
she sounds a bit tipsy didn't she she
writes me
she's a bit different first i too would
let billy joe armstrong pierce me with a
suspicious needle without question so i
can't judge you at all for that only
that you didn't insist he go bigger with
something that would last
secondly i assume many people's parents
behave this way when it comes to their
children permanently marking their
bodies despite the advancement of tattoo
removal but listening to your mom at the
end of the podcast all i could think was
oh that is totally my mother the what
the [ __ ] did you do i however let my
mother see my tattoo despite hearing
that it was the mark of the devil and
looked trashy so i wonder what her
tattoo is what if it's the mark of the
devil what if it's 666 maybe
funny
and her mother is completely justified
and very angry she's just being matter
of fact about it she's like oh it's the
mark of the devil
she's not saying
with any hint of
anything i however let my mother see my
tattoo just by hearing that it was the
most the mark of the devil and looked
trashy okay it was like 666 on a trash
can
look tragic so finally here is your
would you rather you know i got kind of
excited i thought maybe i was like holy
[ __ ] what if we have the same money
that's what i was afraid of you got
excited well excited and scared that
would mean that our mother had an ex
fair i didn't think it through yeah yeah
oh my god let's not think okay so don't
think about it okay so
oh my god
so finally here's your would you rather
would you rather tell your mother our
mother i guess she means that you've
been tattooed for real
she uses a lot of
commas and
would you rather tell your mother that
you've been tattooed for rio with a
lasting tattoo or
hang up the mic and never podcast again
that's a good question how much do you
like being on a podcast oh i definitely
choose the podcast
i i wouldn't even quit the podcast no no
i would i would get a tattoo yeah
yeah you would yeah if it meant not
beginning to do this oh you really like
doing this i love doing this wow yeah
what all right then that big question
what would i get what would you get and
how would you you don't tell her i wish
because think it through
it would be really hard to tell her and
it would
i think kind of sucked to have a tattoo
it would suck but not if it was like
like the one i had that she's
referencing was a little star it was a
little heart that's right worse than a
star well what would you get well you
can't say i want anywhere well see i
wish i knew i wish there were different
parameters i wish you were more specific
about the tattoo because then it would
be more difficult questions right if it
was like a face tattoo
excuse me right a face tattoo would be
tough if it was like a face of gaddafi
um a face of gaddafi on my face
on your neck uh a gaddafi neck tattoo
hmm is gaddafi spelled with a g or a q i
sometimes see it spelled with a q
uh i thought it was g
yeah but maybe that's the uh he was an
unattractive man holy [ __ ]
well i would i i'd actually this kind of
reminds me of uh earlier would you
rather i would rather have in on
attraction yeah my neck then
tom brady on my neck origins of
washington that's true because then it
would then it would make my face well
more attractive yeah but qaddafi's
different than like i'm trying to think
of a i don't want to say
a non-desperate
who's like a nice unattractive person
and i wouldn't want to say that to
insult them but um
because gaddafi on your neck is like i
mean he's uh he's right despicable
that's true um but then and denzel
washington's so cool that's true uh okay
let's see if it was a neck tattoo of
let's say somebody neutral like um
uh
how about this a neck tattoo that you
said in cursive writing rock and roll
on your neck oh my and apostrophe rock
and roll in kind of like glittery
oh man okay um how big is it it's pretty
small it's like
an inch and a half tall i'd wear so many
images
uh wide long rock and roll rock oh [ __ ]
i might have to give up the podcast i
don't know if i could do that
i don't know
i don't know if i could do that rock and
roll i mean for how i mean in that case
in that case the podcast is the tattoo
itself is so much worse than having to
tell our mother about it
oh yeah i mean that would suck oh yeah
but having to live without your neck my
god but if it's this how about this a
little tiny heart on your left butt
cheek oh
i do that so it's just about having on
your body funny and telling
our mother
definitely i'd choose you to do that yes
of course i would i would do a little
heart
i think that's what the question really
was i might actually do a little hard on
the neck
wow and do the podcast i really like
doing the podcast i well that's what
this type of this is rather has revealed
yeah yeah okay well
what would you do
uh rock and roll or the podcast yeah
i really like doing the podcast too oh
rock it's so funny to imagine you for
the rock and roll what about a little
you know little things no you can't
cover it up you can't wear makeup over
here how about this because she
mentioned the devil mark of the devil
what if it was you know those little toy
like mischievous devils that you see on
like uh you see on like truck flaps you
know those little like guys who are like
i know you're talking about yeah like
impish devils like a little cheer
cherubic devil that's funny what about
that on your neck
and it's small it's like an inch big
like right here underneath my ear yeah
yeah and i couldn't cover it up i mean
that has to be part of it because
otherwise you just put a little cover up
you could put like a nelly band-aid yeah
you could put a cover up or put some
makeup on it all the time maybe that's
what maybe nelly lost it but maybe
nellie is a little like but we saw nelly
on some show the other night yeah he
didn't have a band-aid that's right
that's right we thought about you
thought about tweeting
watch oh dancing with the stars i think
i did tweet it oh no no i didn't tweet
it i put it on instagram i know you
should i made it funny right how was it
recently i made a dad joke you said uh
what was it i i'm watching nelly on
dance with it which is funny that you're
watching tennessee
um what did i say i was i'm watching uh
at nelly on dance from the start so glad
to see he's finally healed
yeah
he did have his band-aid yeah maybe he
did tweet it i thought it was so funny
uh
it's funny that his cheek his cheek
wound finally healed
um
yeah i would i would definitely if it i
mean it depends on what it is but it
would really suck to not do the podcast
it would so i i mean really suck also to
have rock
on your neck i think rock and roll is
worse than the little depth cherubic
devil oh yeah yeah because that's kind
of funny rock and roll
you would have to explain that it's
ironic
yeah but you can't explain that to
everyone exactly that you're passing by
but now see a thing like that that's
that's embarrassing uh that the the
optics of which are like embarrassing to
the public it's less so now i mean
that's you know because the time we live
in now and after hearing
yeah i mean it might be like that for a
while so it's like okay i live with this
thing that not that many people see
right but i get to keep doing the
pockets we got a tattoo would you rather
on this episode
yes that's right she has tattoos she
does and her husband's a
tattoo tattooman and not a skater
okay um let's see would you rather okay
we did that love what you two and your
crew pull off thanks emily
and thanks emily thanks emily thanks
emily that's really nice and thanks for
that thought provoking yeah would you
rather and thank you to our guest lake
bell that was a fun conversation really
fun really fun
oh good because it was great to catch up
with her i hadn't seen her in two it had
been too long
she is uh she's a she's a great chatter
yes um so thanks like and looking
forward to her next movie too because
god i love that uh yeah no worries
so thank you lake and
uh best of
best wishes to everyone yeah that's
you're not you're not getting better and
now i'm terrible at it because you know
why i think subconsciously i like the
podcast so much that i don't like even
ending the episode very optimistic all
right well i'll end it okay uh see you
next week everyone
life could be a dream
life
life is short is hosted by me
life is short is attempted to be hosted
by me justin long it is produced and
co-hosted by you christian law also
produced by megan monaco senior producer
is michelle miesh lance audio engineer
is sergio enriquez with two executive
producers one of whom is marshall louis
and ernan lopez for wondering
bye
[Music]
came from whole foods i think but i used
every speculum somehow
oh good you didn't oh way to bury the
lead wow so you were able to use it well
you're welcome
yeah what'd you say i said you're
welcome you're chiding me for it well
honey you shouldn't
you know it's 39 cents a pound i know it
kills me
when you do things like that
maybe it's more now but but it's good
you said it's good sugar
oh it is delicious well there you go i
mean you know you're only young
yeah you enjoyed it
you enjoyed it life is short
i don't know where you feel oh that
sounds like a [ __ ] yeah it should be
you